Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Happy Christmas. Go on, Dominic. You're allowed to say Happy Christmas too. Honestly, the Scrooge-like figure
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。如果你想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、提前解锁系列内容，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。圣诞快乐。来吧，多米尼克。你也允许说“圣诞快乐”。说实话，那个像吝啬鬼似的人物
glowering at the screen. It's Christmas Day. It's the birth of our saviour. Very happy Christmas to all our listeners. Domin dominic is glaring away in the background i was just wondering if you were going to keep talking you will leave me a cap for me i'd offer the festive greeting well merry christmas everybody welcome to the first of our 12 days of christmas podcasts and you can already see the spirit in which this will unfold so okay tom explain that this is all your idea uh the reason i'm doing nothing but podcasting between now
正怒视着屏幕。今天是圣诞节。今天是我们的救世主诞生的日子。祝所有的听众圣诞快乐。多、多米尼克在背景里怒目而视，我刚刚还在想你是不是打算一直说下去，你会给我留个杯子吗？我会送上节日祝福的。好吧，大家圣诞快乐，欢迎收听我们的“圣诞十二日”播客系列的第一期。你们已经能看出这期节目会以怎样的画风展开了。好吧，汤姆，解释一下，这全都是你的主意。嗯，我从现在到
july christmas day is because of you and this crackpot wheeze of yours so explain it to the listeners please well so um we're not going to be putting out the regular um pair of episodes instead we're making we're going to make it much harder for ourselves. And we're going to do a succession of podcasts themed around the concept of the 12 days of Christmas, which is, of course, a very sacral idea. Very sacral. Do you know what it originates in, Dominic? Christianity. Yeah, it originates in Christianity.
七月圣诞节除了做播客什么都不干，全都是因为你和你的这个疯狂怪招。所以请跟听众们解释一下吧。好的，所以呢，呃，我们不会发布常规的、呃，那对儿节目，相反，我们会进行调整，我们要给自己增加很多难度。我们要制作一系列以“圣诞十二日”为主题的播客，这当然是一个非常神圣的概念。非常神圣。你知道它的起源是什么吗，多米尼克？基督教。是的，它起源于基督教。
And specifically, the Council of Tor in 56 Christianity. Yeah, it originates in Christianity. And specifically the Council of Tor in 567. Wow, I didn't know that. The 12 days following Christmas will be a time of festive reflection. But it's not the Council of Tor that dictates the pear tree and people sleeping or whatever. That's later. So lots of people think that, you know, you have Christmas and then it's over on Boxing Day and you go to the sales. But of course, that's not the case. Christmas goes on until either the 5th of January or the 6th of January, depending on whether you start the 12 days of Christmas from Christmas Day or from the day after Christmas Day.
具体来说是公元567年的图尔公会议。基督教。是的，它起源于基督教。具体来说是公元567年的图尔公会议。哇，我不知道这件事。圣诞节之后的十二天将是节日反思的时期。但规定了梨树、人们睡觉或诸如此类东西的并不是图尔公会议。那是后来的事。所以很多人认为，你知道的，过完圣诞节，到了节礼日就结束了，然后你去大采购。但当然，情况并非如此。圣诞节一直持续到1月5日或1月6日，这取决于你是从圣诞节当天还是从圣诞节的第二天开始计算圣诞十二日。
We are going to do, we're basically doing the 13 days. Yeah, we're doing both, aren't we? Unlucky for some. So, and the idea is that each day we're going to discuss an event that happened on one of the 12 days of Christmas. And I've chosen one and Dominic has chosen one. So, Dominic, shall we reveal to the listeners how this works by saying what have you chosen?
我们要做的是，我们基本上要做13天。是的，我们两个都做，对吧？对某些人来说不太吉意。所以，我们的想法是，每天我们要讨论一件发生在圣诞十二日期间的事件。我选了一个，多米尼克选了一个。那么，多米尼克，我们要不要向听众们揭晓这是怎么运作的，说说你选了什么？
Okay. So I've chosen a very festive seasonal anniversary. So 25th of December, 1991, it's the end of the Soviet Union. Nothing. Nothing. Nothing screams the festive spirit. Like a discussion of the end of the Soviet Union.
好吧。我选择了一个非常应景的季节性纪念日。1991年12月25日，苏联解体。没有什么。没有什么。没有什么比讨论苏联解体更能洋溢着节日气氛了。
I think when people... You're preparing your turkey, you're sorting out your Brussels sprouts. Tree. Mikhail Gorbachev. Economic reform has gone wrong. That's what people think about at Christmas isn't it
我想当人们……你在准备火鸡，你在整理抱子甘蓝。树。米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫。经济改革出了问题。这才是人们在圣诞节想到的事情，对吧？
so ho ho ho ho ho and do you know what I've gone for well you do because I've already told you yeah because it was written down in front of me
所以，霍、霍、霍、霍，你知道我选了什么吗？好吧，你知道，因为我已经告诉你了。是的，因为就写在我面前的纸上。
I have chosen the coronation of Charlemagne in Rome on Christmas day well that's a very I mean that's probably 8800
我选择了查理曼在圣诞节于罗马加冕。好吧，这非常……我的意思是，这大概是公元800年。
and again nothing screams Christmas like listening to someone going on about international politics in the ninth century but you know what tom i think that's probably the most famous thing other than christmas to have happened on christmas day isn't it possibly the coronation william the conqueror no the coronation of charlemagne is more famous yeah i think it is it is yes and it's it's and we've chosen i mean not so not all the episodes that
同样，没有什么比听人喋喋不休地谈论9世纪的国际政治更能体现圣诞节气氛的了，但你知道吗，汤姆，我认为这可能是除圣诞节本身之外，在圣诞节那天发生的最著名的事件了，不是吗？可能是征服者威廉的加冕？不，查理曼的加冕更著名。是的，我认为是的，确实如此，而且我们选择的——也就是说，并非我们选择的所有节目
we've chosen are going to be quite as seismic and historic but both both our choices are very very historic um and uh i guess we should crack on so i have yeah so i've chosen the coronation of charlemagne charlemagne titanic figure in the history of um western europe we have we haven't done yet but we could absolutely do um an episode on in due course. Set the scene, Tom. Where and when are we? So Charlemagne is the king of the Franks. And the Franks have emerged in the centuries that have followed the collapse of the Roman Empire in the West as the most powerful kingdom in what had been the Roman Empire in the West.
都会像这个一样具有划时代的重大历史意义，但我们俩的选择都非常非常具有历史意义，嗯，我想我们该言归正传了。所以我有，是的，所以我选择了查理曼的加冕。查理曼是西欧历史上的泰斗。我们还没做过，但我们完全可以在适的时候做一期关于他的节目。设定一下背景，汤姆。我们在哪里，现在是什么时候？所以查理曼是法兰克人的国王。而在西罗马帝国崩溃后的几个世纪里，法兰克人已经崛起为原西罗马帝国领土上最强大的王国。
There are other players in Christian Europe, the two most significant of which are the emperor in Constantinople, who rules in a direct line of succession from the Roman Empire of the East. Well, they sort of think of themselves as the Romans. Yeah, all the way back to Augustus. And the bishop of Rome, the Pope, who is the Bishop of one of the most important city in the Christian world.
在基督教欧洲还有其他玩家，其中最重要的两个是：君士坦丁堡的皇帝，他直接继承自东罗马帝国的世袭正统。好吧，他们有点把自己当成罗马人。是的，一直追溯到奥古斯都。以及罗马主教，即教皇，他是基督教世界最重要的城市之一的主教。
So there are five patriarchs. There's the Patriarch of Rome, of Constantinople, of Antioch, of Jerusalem, and of Alexandria. Is Rome more important than Constantinople? Surely not. Yes, it is. of Antioch, of Jerusalem, and of Alexandria. Is Rome more important than Constantinople? Surely not. Yes, it is. It is because it's where Peter and Paul were martyred and are buried, and it was the original capital of the Roman Empire.
所以有五个牧首。有罗马牧首、君士坦丁堡牧首、安条克牧首、耶路撒冷牧首和亚历山大牧首。罗马比君士坦丁堡更重要吗？当然不可能。是的，它就是。安条克牧首、耶路撒冷牧首和亚历山大牧首。罗马比君士坦丁堡更重要吗？当然不可能。是的，它就是。因为那是彼得和保罗殉道并安葬的地方，而且它曾是罗马帝国的原首都。
But the people in Constantinople wouldn't have said that, would they? Well, so this is a kind of long-running fracture point, a stress point. So the patriarchies of Alexandria, of Jerusalemusalem and of antioch have come under muslim rule uh constantinople obviously directly under the thumb of the emperor in in constantinople the bishop of rome in a slightly ambiguous position uh and an exposed position because um the romans the byzantines whatever it becomes incredibly confusing because you never know
但君士坦丁堡的人可不会这么说，对吧？好吧，所以这是一个长期存在的断裂点、压力点。因此，亚历山大、耶路撒冷和安条克的牧首区已经落入了穆斯林统治之下；君士坦丁堡显然直接受制于君士坦丁堡的皇帝；罗马主教处于一个略显暧昧的位置，也是一个脆弱的位置，因为……罗马人、拜占庭人，无论怎么称呼它都会变得极其混乱，因为你永远不知道
when you're talking about the romans whether you mean the people from rome or whether you mean the romans of byzantium but let's call them byzantines um have reconquered much of italy but it's kind of frayed away um and the pope is essentially he's the servant of the the emperor in constantinople he he's a subject of the emperor in constantinople. And every time a Pope is elected, he sends the news directly to the Emperor in Constantinople. However, the problem is that Byzantine control over Italy is threatened by various barbarian peoples, of whom the most significant are the Lombards. And the Lombards are constantly pressing down on Rome and the Bishop of Rome wants to keep his independence. So by the 8th century, the Pope is starting to look around for another protector. And the obvious person to turn to is the King of the Franks.
当你谈论罗马人时，你是指来自罗马的人，还是指拜占庭的罗马人，但我们称他们为拜占庭人吧——他们已经收复了大部分意大利，但这种统治已经有点瓦解了，教皇基本上是君士坦丁堡皇帝的奴仆，他是君士坦丁堡皇帝的臣民。而且每当选出一位教皇，他都会直接将消息发送给君士坦丁堡的皇帝。然而，问题在于，拜占庭对意大利的控制受到了各种蛮族人民的威胁，其中最重要的是伦巴第人。伦巴第人不断向罗马施压，而罗马主教希望保持其独立性。因此到了8世纪，教皇开始寻找另一个保护者。而显而易见的人选就是法兰克国王。
Right, because they're the big power in Western Europe, aren't they? The big power in Western Europe. So one of the Popes goes, he crosses the Alps and he goes to Francia. What are the Franks looking for? Well, as it so happens, there's just been a regime change in Francia. The Merovingian dynasty, the original dynasty of the Franks has been toppled. And the pretenders, the line of Charles Carolus, so Charles Martel, who defeated the Saracens at the Battle of Tours, the Carolingians, as we call them, they are looking for the kind of legitimacy that only the Bishop of Rome can provide.
没错，因为他们是西欧的大国，对吧？西欧的大国。所以其中一位教皇出发了，他翻越阿尔卑斯山去了法兰克尼亚。法兰克人想要什么？好吧，碰巧的是，法兰克尼亚刚刚发生了一场政权更迭。墨洛温王朝，法兰克人的原始王朝已经被推翻了。而那些觊觎王位的人，即查理（卡洛斯）的家族，也就是在图尔战役中击败萨拉森人的查理·马特，也就是我们所说的加洛林王朝，他们正在寻找那种唯有罗马主教才能提供的合法性。
And so the Pope zips over the Alps. He crowns Pepin, who's the son of Charles Martel, as king. And basically it's a kind of, you know, it's a match made in heaven. The Pope benefits, the Carolingians benefit. So Charlemagne is the son of Pepin. He's become absolutely the grand fromage of Latin Western Europe. He's conquered the Saxons. He's pushed into Eastern Europe. He's defeated the Saracens in Spain. Everything's going tremendously well for him. Then there is a crisis in Rome.
于是教皇飞越阿尔卑斯山。他给查理·马特的儿子丕平加冕为王。基本上这是一场天作之合。教皇受益了，加洛林王朝也受益了。所以查理曼是丕平的儿子。他已经绝对成为了拉丁西欧的大红人。他征服了萨克森人。他向东欧推进。他在西班牙击败了萨拉森人。他的一切都进展得极其顺利。然后罗马爆发了危机。
And Dominic, I'm aware that I've been talking a lot. Do you have anything to contribute to this topic? Nothing. Absolutely nothing. Speak to, carry on talking. I'm interested. I'm listening to the story. It's Christmas Day.
多米尼克，我意识到我一直在说个不停。你对这个话题有什么要补充的吗？没有。绝对没有。你讲吧，继续说。我很感兴趣。我在听故事。今天是圣诞节。
I'm busy cooking my goose. And I'm listening. I'm thinking, what do I want? I want Tom Holland to talk to me about the Franks. So nothing. I mean, what is more festive um a tale of maiming go on then name away so 795 yeah uh a pope called hadrian i um who is a roman aristocrat very very connected um being very very popular with the uh the carolingians he dies and he gets succeeded
我在忙着烤我的鹅。我在听。我在想，我想要什么？我想要汤姆·霍兰跟我讲法兰克人。所以没有。我是说，还有什么比一个关于肢解的故事更具有节日气氛呢？讲吧，大肆肢解吧。所以795年，是的，一个名叫哈德良一世的教皇，他是一位罗马贵族，背景非常深厚，与加洛林王朝关系极为密切，他去世了，接替他的是
by a guy who takes on the name of leo the third okay um and leo's background is is much less exclusive and so hadrian's relatives are a bit resentful of this you know feel he's a bit of a parven a bit of an upstart yeah and so they they essentially they're they're kind of bubbling away in the background their cross and they seize in 799 they ambush leo and they blind him and they cut his tongue out that's kind of always the way though isn't it in this period blinding cutting off people's noses all that sort of stuff is very much par for the course yeah but what happens next is not par for the course and this is where it's a christmas miracle because what then happens is leo escapes and miraculously he regains his sight and he regains his ability to talk okay so that suggests to me that both the blinding and the tongue severing
一个名叫利奥三世的人。好吧，嗯，利奥的背景远没有那么显赫，所以哈德良的亲戚对此有些怨恨，你知道的，觉得他有点像个暴发户，是个无名小卒。所以他们基本上在暗地里酝酿不满，并在799年绑架了利奥，弄瞎了他的眼睛，还割掉了他的舌头。这在这个时期似乎总是家常便饭，不是吗？弄瞎眼睛、割掉鼻子之类的事情简直是司空见惯。是的，但接下来发生的事情可不是司空见惯的，这就是一个圣诞奇迹了，因为接下来发生的事是利奥逃脱了，奇迹般地，他恢复了视力，也恢复了说话的能力。好吧，这向我表明，弄瞎眼睛和割舌头
were not they they were not carried out properly they were carried out incompet. Or it happened that through God's full knowledge and action, Leo recovered his sight and his tongue was restored to him so he could speak. Okay, well, that's a different interpretation. So either it didn't happen or God made it happen. Yeah, it's Christmas, so let's say it did happen. So Leo, having done his escape and had this miraculous recovery, he scarpers off north to meet Charlemagne, who is hanging out in Saxony. Charlemagne basically means Carolus Magnus, isn't it?
根本没有……它们没有被妥善执行，执行得很业余。或者通过上帝的全知全能和介入，利奥恢复了视力，他的舌头也失而复得，所以他能够说话了。好吧，那是另一种解释。所以要么这件事没发生，要么是上帝让它发生的。好吧，今天是圣诞节，所以我们就算它发生了。所以利奥在逃跑并经历了这种奇迹般的康复之后，北逃去见正在萨克森逗留的查理曼。查理曼基本上就是卡洛斯·马格努斯的意思，对吧？
Charles the Great. Charles the Great, yeah. And Charles comes to meet him, and they meet up at a place called Paderborn. Leo stays there for three months. They commune. They chat away. Clearly something is brewing.
查理大帝。查理大帝，是的。然后查理来见他，他们在帕德博恩这个地方碰面。利奥在那里呆了三个月。他们交流。他们聊天。显然有什么事情正在酝酿。
And then Leo goes back to Rome. And for a year, they don't see each other then on the 23rd of november 800 charlemagne is approaching rome with a great army great retinue and leo goes out to meet him and they come into rome yeah and charlemagne has come basically to legitimate leo's papacy so he convenes a synod. He exonerates Leo of all the charges that have been brought against him by his enemies. He affirms the fact that, you know, a pope can't be judged. He's the pope.
然后利奥回到了罗马。有一年的时间，他们没有见面，直到公元800年11月23日，查理曼带着大军和庞大的随从队伍接近罗马，利奥出来迎接他，他们进入了罗马。查理曼来这里的目的基本上是为了赋予利奥的教皇身份合法性，所以他召集了一次主教会议。他洗清了利奥受到敌人指控的所有罪名。他确认了这样一个事实，即教皇是不能被审判的。他是教皇。
And this is so basically Charlemagne by now is in Rome. Other things, however, simultaneously are happening in the background. So on the theme of mutilation, you said how mutilation is very Christmassy, but a key part of what's going on here. So meanwhile, in Constantinople, so three years earlier in 797, you have one of the great women of Byzantine history, Irene, of an aristocratic Athenian family, who's gone to Constantinople, married, had a son. This son has become Constantine VI. But in Irene's opinion, in mum's opinion,
所以基本上查理曼此时已经在罗马了。然而，与此同时，背景中也发生着其他事情。关于残废这个主题，你刚才说残废非常具有圣诞节气氛，这其实是其中正在发生的事情的一个关键部分。与此同时，在君士坦丁堡，也就是三年前的797年，拜占庭历史上最伟大的女性之一出现了——来自雅典贵族家庭的伊琳娜，她去了君士坦丁堡，结婚并生了一个儿子。这个儿子成为了君士坦丁之六世。但在伊琳娜看来，在母亲看来，
he doesn't measure up. So do you know what Irene does? Blinds him. Cuts out some time. Yeah, blinds him. Blinds him. And she basically becomes empress.'s her own son this is yeah she blinds her own son that is very poor parenting it's strict isn't it yeah it's harsh um and any parents out there with difficult toddlers or it's christmas and the tempers do get fraught don't go don't don't go the full irene um so so you've got charlemagne in rome
他不合标准。所以你知道伊琳娜做了什么吗？弄瞎了他的眼睛。割掉了一些时间。是的，弄瞎了他。弄瞎了他。她基本上成了女皇。这是她自己的亲儿子。是的，她弄瞎了自己的亲儿子。这育儿方式可真够差的。很严厉，对吧？是的，很残酷。任何家里有难缠幼儿的父母，或者正值圣诞节脾气容易暴躁的时候，千万别学——别走伊琳娜的全套路线。所以，你有了罗马的查理曼，
you've got an empress in constantinople and then on the 23rd of december a further miraculous episode so two um sorry three of charlemagne's servants arrive from Jerusalem yeah and they are bringing with them the keys to the holy sepulcher and a holy banner oh that's nice and it's a miracle it's another Christmas miracle they've turned up two days before Christmas yeah incredible odds against that you don't reckon they arrived early and were just waiting outside to kind of well that would be the perspective of a cynical 21st century historian yeah again let's run with the idea of a Christmas miracle so everything is coming together so there's this idea that um charlemagne is now the guardian of the holy sepulcher in jerusalem you know very holy uh the the pope is there he's beholden to charlemagne
你有了君士坦丁堡的女皇，然后在12月23日，又发生了一段奇迹般的插曲：查理曼的两名，抱歉，三名仆人从耶路撒冷抵达了，是的，他们带来了圣墓教堂的钥匙和一面圣旗。哦，那太棒了。这是一个奇迹，又一个圣诞奇迹，他们在圣诞节前两天出现了。是的，几率太低了。你不觉得他们提前到达，只是在外面等着，好……好吧，那会是一个愤世嫉俗的21世纪历史学家的视角。是的，我们还是顺着圣诞奇迹的思路来吧。所以一切都在汇聚，因此有这样一种观点，即查理曼现在是耶路撒冷圣墓教堂的守护者，你知道的，非常神圣；教皇也在那里，他受制于查理曼；
um the empress in constantinople that's looking illegitimate i say on the 25th of December, Charlemagne is crowned as emperor, not as king, but as emperor in Rome. And the idea there is that the line of emperors in Rome that had been extinguished with Romulus Augustulus back in the 5th century has now been revitalized. So just as in the 4th and the 5th centuries, you might have two emperors in the Roman Empire. Ever since the 5th century, there's only been the one, the fifth centuries you might have two emperors in the roman emperor yeah in the roman empire ever since the fifth century there's only been the one the one in constantinople now with the crowning of charlemagne there are two once again and he's crowned by the eastern roman empire and the western roman he is crowned by the pope now did charlemagne know what was coming this is the big question so there's um a guy called einhardt who's a monk who um writes a life of charlemagne that's modeled on satonius's lives of the caesars yeah and he says that at first charlemagne was so averse to receiving the name of emperor that
君士坦丁堡的女皇，看起来不合合法。我说，在12月25日，查理曼加冕为皇帝，不是作为国王，而是作为罗马皇帝。这里的想法是，在5世纪随着奥古斯都·罗慕路斯而熄灭的罗马皇帝世系现在已经重获生机。就像在4世纪和5世纪，罗马帝国可能会有两个皇帝一样。自5世纪以来，只有一个皇帝，5世纪以来你可能有两个皇帝，在罗马帝国里，自从5世纪以来一直只有一个，君士坦丁堡的那个。现在随着查理曼的加冕，再次有了两个。他是由东罗马帝国和西罗马帝国加冕的，他是由教皇加冕的。现在查理曼知道接下来会发生什么吗？这是一个重大问题。所以有一个
he said he would never have entered the church that day even though it was the most important feast day if he had known the pope's plan beforehand so charlemagne shocked shocked to discover that he's being crowned as emperor but i think almost certainly charlemagne absolutely knew what was happening yeah um and i think the key the key proof of that really is the incredibly serendipitous if it is just serendipitous, turning up of the people from Jerusalem. It's obviously stage-mannered to make it look as good as possible. And a contemporary chronicler gives three reasons why it's legitimate for Charlemagne to be crowned as Roman emperor. Are you going to tell us?
名叫艾因哈德的修道士，他模仿苏埃托尼乌斯的《罗马十二帝王传》写了一本《查理曼传》，他写道，起初查理曼对获得“皇帝”这个称号是如此反感，以至于他说，如果他事先知道教皇的计划，即使那天是最高庆节，他绝不会走进那座教堂。所以查理曼震惊了，震惊于发现自己被加冕为皇帝。但我认为几乎可以肯定，查理曼绝对知道发生了什么，而且我认为这最关键的证明，实际上是耶路撒冷的人们极其机缘巧合的到来——如果这仅仅是机缘巧合的话。这显然是经过精心编排的，为了让它看起来尽可能完美。一位当代编年史家给出了查理曼加冕为罗马皇帝合法的三个理由。你打算告诉我们吗？
I know you are. I am. I can see you looking at your notes. I am. Tell us the three reasons. One of them is that you have a woman ruling as emperor in Constantinople. Okay, that's... So this is a sexist era, and this is viewed as being...
我知道你会的。是的。我能看出你在看笔记。我是。告诉我们这三个理由。其中之一是君士坦丁堡现在由一位女性作为女皇统治。好吧，那是……这是一个性别歧视的时代，这被视为……
Yes, shocking. Unacceptable. The second is that Rome is the seat of the Caesars, the ancestral seat of the Caesars, and it is now effectively under the protection of Charlemagne, and so therefore he should be emperor. That's a terrible reason, because I mean... That's a good reason. Rome has been under the protection of Charlemagne. And so, therefore, he should be emperor. That's a terrible reason. That's a good reason.
是的，令人震惊。不可接受。第二个理由是罗马是凯萨的宝座，是凯萨的祖传宝座，现在它实际上在查理曼的保护之下，因此他应该成为皇帝。这是一个糟糕的理由，因为……这是一个好理由。罗马一直受到查理曼的保护，因此，他应该成为皇帝。这是一个糟糕的理由。这是一个好理由。
Rome has been under the protection of lots of people in the intervening 324 years. Yeah, but the Byzantine, you know, Irene can't come to, you know, muscle in on the Lombards. Charlemagne's defeated the Lombards. But previous people haven't crowned themselves emperor, have they? I mean, you know, Theodoric the Ostrogoth or whatever these people are called who've been in charge of Rome.
在过去的324年里，罗马一直受到许多人的保护。是的，但是拜占庭，你知道的，伊琳娜不能来，你知道的，插手伦巴第的事。查理曼击败了伦巴第人。但以前的人并没有为自己加冕为皇帝，不是吗？我的意思是，你知道的，东哥特人狄奥德里克或者无论这些管过罗马的人叫什么名字。
Yeah, but that's because the third reason, Charles Dominion now ranks as an empire because he has many provinces. Yeah. Okay. That's a good reason because he is ruling an empire. Yeah. Isn't he?
是的，但那是因为第三个理由：由于查理拥有许多行省，他的领地现在已升格为一个帝国。是的。好吧。这是一个好理由，因为他统治着一个帝国。不是吗？
So for those reasons, it's viewed as absolutely legitimate. So Charlemagne becomes emperor. And that's the dawn of the Holy Roman Empire, right and that's the dawn of the holy roman empire right it's the dawn of the holy roman empire i mean there will be a break because um charlemagne furiously divides his empire up so it kind of gets increasingly fragmented um the figure of the the emperors who succeed him become increasingly kind of wraith-like and spectral and finally they vanish completely um and that but and it's not until the 10th century when Otto the Great, friend of the show that hairy chested
所以基于这些原因，它被视为完全合法的。于是查理曼成为了皇帝。这就是神圣罗马帝国的黎明，对吧？这就是神圣罗马帝国的黎明，对吧？这是神圣罗马帝国的黎明。我的意思是，将会有一个破裂，因为查理曼愤怒地将他的帝国瓜分了，所以它变得越来越碎片化，继承他的皇帝们的形象也变得越来越像幽灵和幻影，最终他们彻底消失了。但直到10世纪，当大奥托——本节目的老朋友，那个莱希费尔德战役中胸毛飘飘的胜利者——再次被加冕为皇帝时，才建立起一条一直延续到拿破仑的连续世系。是的，但从那时起，从奥托开始，神圣罗马帝国基本上就是德国，对吧？
victor at the Battle of the Lechfield is crowned emperor again and that then establishes the continuous line that runs right the way through to Napoleon Yeah, but at that point from Otto onwards the Holy Roman Empire is basically Germany isn't it
附带了一点意大利北部。然后拿破仑，他的加冕典礼是以查理曼的加冕为蓝本的，不是吗？但他为自己加冕，所以教皇在那里，但没有为他加冕。所以这非常具有节日气氛，汤姆。是的，我的意思是，没有什么比
with a bit of northern Italy attached and then Napoleon, his coronation is modelled on Charlem is basically Germany, isn't it, with a bit of northern Italy attached. And then Napoleon, his coronation is modelled on Charlemagne's coronation, isn't it? But he crowns himself, so the Pope is there, but doesn't crown him. So that's very festive, Tom. Yeah, I think, I mean, nothing more festive than
几次盲刑更具节日气氛了。好吧，其实还有更具节日气氛的事情。那是什么，多米尼克？那是20世纪80年代末和90年代初的苏联政治。中场休息过后，我们将转入这个话题。所以准备好，准备好你的圣诞拉炮，准备好卷肠猪肉，米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫要来了。
a few blindings. Well, there is actually something more festive. What does that, Dominic? That's Soviet politics in the late 1980s and early 1990s. And that's what we'll turn to next after the break. So get ready, get your Christmas crackers ready, prepare the pigs and blankets, Mikhail Gorbachev is coming.
休息后见。我们主持《娱乐至死》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们还会揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和提前购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentment.com。
See you after the break. we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
你好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》的圣诞节特辑，这是我们的“圣诞十二日”特别节目的第一期。我们正在回顾几十年前、几百年前、几千年前的今天发生的事件。在第一部分中，我们探讨了公元800年的今天查理曼在罗马的加冕礼。现在，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，你将通过给我们讲述苏联的解到来触动节日的温情脉脉。有趣的是，这是在圣诞节，但对于事情发生的俄罗斯来说，那天并不是圣诞节。
Hello, welcome back to uh christmas day on the rest is history uh and it's the first of our 12 days of christmas specials uh we are looking at events that happened on this day uh decades centuries millennia ago who knows um in the first, we looked at the coronation of Charlemagne in Rome on this day in AD 800. And now, Dominic Sandbrook, you are going to tickle the festive underbelly by telling us all about the end of the Soviet Union. Well, the funny thing is this is on Christmas Day, but it wasn't Christmas Day in Russia where it happens.
所以很明显他们的圣诞节要晚得多。我甚至不记得东正教圣诞节是哪一天，但那是1月的某一天，对吧？所以对他们来说这不是圣诞节。这是1991年12月25日，我们在莫斯科的克里姆林宫，米哈伊尔·谢尔盖耶维奇·戈尔巴乔夫即将辞去苏联总统职务，这个国家只剩下最后几个小时，实际上已经名存实亡了。所以这是一个非同寻常的时刻。弗拉基米尔·普京称这是20世纪最大的地缘政治悲剧。克格勃到这个时候已经被废除了吗？
So obviously they have their Christmas much later. I can't even remember what day the Orthodox Christmas is on, but it's some day in January, isn't it? So this isn't Christmas Day for them. So this is the 25th of December 1991, and we are in the Kremlin in Moscow, and Mikhail Sergeyevich Gorbachev, is about to resign as president of the Soviet Union, a state which has only hours left and is kind of dead already, actually. So it's an extraordinary moment. Vladimir Putin says this is the greatest kind of geopolitical tragedy of the 20th century. Has the KGB been abolished by this point?
我想它在名义上被废除了，但在……但它仍然在周围徘徊。是的，它在周围徘徊。尽管许多克格勃官员，像普京一样，完全感到困惑和震惊。俄罗斯有一种令人难以置信的、狂热的不确定感。想到在1991年年初的时候，
I think it's sort of been abolished in name, but not in... But still, he's hovering around. Yeah, he's hovering around. Although a lot of KGB officers, like Putin, are kind of completely discombobulated and astonished. There's an incredible sense of kind of febrile uncertainty in Russia. And it's extraordinary to think that basically at the beginning of the year, 1991,
冷战显然已经结束了。柏林墙已经倒塌。东欧不再是共产主义的了。但没有人认为苏联会自行消亡。我的意思是，它依然存在。CIA的分析师等等，他们不认为它会去任何地方。因为我们应该解释一下，它是一个联盟。所以它的绝大部分是俄罗斯，
the Cold War is obviously over. The Berlin Wall has fallen. Eastern Europe is no longer communist. But nobody thinks the Soviet Union is going to wither away. I mean, it's still there. And CIA analysts and so on, they don't think it's going anywhere. Because we should explain, shouldn't we, that it's a union. So the vast majority of it is Russia
但你也有……所有这些其他的共和国。波罗的海国家、乌克兰、格鲁吉亚。中亚或高加索地区。“斯坦”国家。没错。我认为西方很多人并没有真正意识到这一点，因为我们一直把俄罗斯和苏联
but you've also got... All these other republics. Baltic states, Ukraine, Georgia. Central Asia or the Caucasians. The Stans. Exactly. And that was something I think that for a lot of people in the West they didn't really appreciate because we'd used Russia and Soviet
混为一谈。就像英格兰和英国一样。没错。这正是即将给苏联政治带来巨大冲击的事情。所以戈尔巴乔夫自1985年以来一直在台。他在西方是个英雄，因为他被视为温和可爱、爱好和平等等。有个有魅力的妻子。你说得对，赖莎，完全正确。他来与里根和撒切尔等人举行首脑会议。但实际上，在俄罗斯，他的支持率一直在直线下降。因为经济一直在直线下降。
interchangeably. Like England and Britain. Exactly. And that's something that's about to sort of really catch up with Soviet politics. So Gorbachev has been in since 1985. He's a hero in the West because he's seen as cuddly and peace-loving and all these kinds of things. Got a glamorous wife. You're right, Raisa, exactly. And he comes and has summits with Reagan and Thatcher and so on. But in reality, in Russia, his popularity has been sinking like a stone. Because the economy has been sinking like a stone.
经济状况糟透了。他试图同时进行政治和经济改革，但没有产生他想要的结果。但他通过同时进行经济改革和政治改革，做了两件事。他疏远了许多普通俄罗斯人，他们的生活水平正在崩塌，在这个新世界里感到迷茫；
The economy has been terrible. He's tried political and economic reform simultaneously and hasn't produced the results that he wanted. But what he's done is by having economic reforms and political reforms simultaneously, he's done two things. He's alienated a lot of ordinary Russians whose living standards are kind of imploding and who sort of feel lost in this new world.
但与此同时，由于他的政治改革走向了某种民主等等，他也疏远了许多他所需要的精英阶层。所以在1991年中期，戈尔巴乔夫陷入了这种可怕的混乱中，没有人支持他。他夹在自由派和保守派之间。就像鲍里斯一样。好吧，那——
But at the same time, he's alienated a lot of the elites that he would need because of his political reforms, because it's sort of moved to some kind of democracy and so on. So by the middle of 1991, Gorbachev is in this dreadful mess where he's sort of – nobody is for him. He's caught between the liberals and the conservatives. Like Boris. Well, that's –
历史上的勇士。是的，嗯，我不确定鲍里斯会不会搞个政变，然后在度假时被软禁在克里米亚之类的地方，不过无论如何，是的，可怜的老戈尔巴乔夫拖着疲惫、受困的身躯去克里米亚度假了，而克里姆林宫的强硬派真的因为他们感到愤怒——
Warriors from history. Yeah, well, I'm not sure that Boris is going to have like a coup and be locked up in the Crimea on on holiday or something um but anyway yes so poor old gorbachev he goes off to the crimea on holiday exhausted beleaguered and hardliners in the kremlin really because they're they're outraged um that he's trying to get through this new treaty to reassert the soviet union a new union treaty with the various republics. And they think that will give away too much power from the centre, and they think this is their last chance to kind of stop him.
因为他试图通过这项新条约来重申苏联的地位，与各共和国签署新的联盟条约。他们认为这会从中央分权太多，他们认为这是他们阻止他的最后机会。
So they launch this coup, where they basically lock him up in his dacha in the Crimea, and then they seize power in Moscow. I remember seeing the evening standard headlines saying coup in so yeah i remember i mean it was extraordinary because it was so control of the missiles it was so incompetent and it was it was but it was played out in the full glare of the media i mean i can remember watching news night on this that when the um the protesters were massing outside the russian parliament building the white house it's called in in Moscow. And there were tanks surrounding them. And there was this standoff.
于是他们发动了这场政变，基本上把他软禁在克里米亚的别墅里，然后在莫斯科夺取了政权。我记得看到《标准晚报》（Evening Standard）的头条写着“莫斯科政变”。是的，我记得——我的意思是这太不寻常了，因为太失控了，控制导弹的权力——太无能了，而且是在媒体的全方位聚焦下进行的。我记得当时在看《新闻之夜》（Newsnight），当时抗议者聚集在俄罗斯议会大楼（在莫斯科被称为白宫）外面。
And basically everybody in the West... And the mayor of Moscow? Well, he's not the mayor of Moscow. What did he say? Boris Yeltsin? He's the leader of the Russian Soviet Republic. So Boris Yeltsin. So you should tell us who Boris Yeltsin is. So Boris Yeltsin is a former...
那里周围都是坦克。有一种对峙的局面。基本上西方所有人都……莫斯科市长呢？好吧，他不是莫斯科市长。他说了什么？鲍里斯·叶利钦？他是俄罗斯苏维埃共和国的领导人。所以是鲍里斯·叶利钦。所以你应该告诉我们鲍里斯·叶利钦是谁。所以鲍里斯·叶利钦曾是一个……
He's been a Communist Party apparatchik, but he has fallen out with Yeltsin is. So Boris Yeltsin is a former, you know, he's been a Communist Party apparatchik, but he has fallen out with Yeltsin, with Gorbachev rather, because Boris Yeltsin has been sort of pushing to go further and faster. They have fallen out. He's made himself very much the face of the kind of reformers. And once Gorbachev is imprisoned by the coup plotters, sort of head of the KGB and the defence ministry and so on. They made the terrible mistake of not locking up Boris Yeltsin
他曾是共产党apparatchik（官僚），但他与叶利钦……叶利钦是谁。所以鲍里斯·叶利钦曾经是一个，你知道的，他曾是共产党官僚，但他与戈尔巴乔夫闹翻了，因为鲍里斯·叶利钦一直在推动走得更快更远。他们闹翻了。他非常明显地将自己塑造为改革派的面孔。一旦戈尔巴乔夫被政变策划者——克格勃负责人、国防部等等——监禁。他们犯了一个巨大的错误，没有逮捕鲍里斯·叶利钦，
because they just think he's a loose cannon and a drunk and a wastrel. It's like the assassins of Caesar, neglecting to arrest Mark Antony. Mark Antony. It's exactly that, actually, Tom. That's a very good parallel. So Yeltsin, of course, then seizes his moment. He jumps onto a tank and he sort of rallies the Russian people.
因为他们认为他只是个不受约束的人、一个酒鬼和浪荡子。这就像凯撒的刺客忽视了逮捕马克·安东尼一样。马克·安东尼。汤姆，确实如此。这是一个非常好的比喻。所以叶利钦当然抓住了这个时机。他跳上一辆坦克，号召俄罗斯人民。
The coup collapses pretty quickly, within days. Gorbachev flies back from the Crimea, but his power has completely... Yeah, he's a broken reed. Yeah, has completely seeped away. And in the next few weeks, there is this sudden, there's this kind of rush of events. So Yeltsin outlaws the Communist Party in Russia
政变很快就崩溃了，在几天内。戈尔巴乔夫从克里米亚飞回，但他的权力已经完全……是的，他成了一个破落户。是的，已经完全消逝了。在接下来的几周里，发生了一场突如其来的、事件的狂潮。所以叶利钦在俄罗斯取缔了共产党，
and the old sort of elite the hardliners so broken by the failure of the coup and so kind of disorientated that they can't stop him so he outlaws the communist party and then you get this sort of domino effect and the key moment i think is on the first of december when ukraine very irrelevant given the headlines in the last few days so ukraine holds a referendum about asserting its sovereignty and basically independence in the Soviet Union. And to a lot of people's astonishment, the Ukraine votes to leave, basically.
老派的精英、强硬派因政变的失败而彻底崩溃，精神恍惚，无法阻止他，所以他取缔了共产党，接着你看到了多米诺骨牌效应，我认为关键时刻是在12月1日，乌克兰——鉴于过去几天的头条新闻，这非常相关——乌克兰举行了一场关于宣示其主权以及基本上在苏联内独立的公投。令许多人惊讶的是，乌克兰投票决定基本上脱离。
On a massive majority. Yeah, extraordinary. And that's a sign of how much the elite sort of driven reforms have alienated people, I think. I mean, obviously, it's a sign of nationalist sentiment and so on. But I think the results take everybody by surprise. Then seven days later, Yeltsin and the leaders of the leader of Ukraine and the leader of Belarus, they meet a base called Belavezha in a kind of hunting lodge behind Gorbachev's back.
以压倒性多数。是的，非同寻常。我认为这表明了精英驱动的改革在多大程度上疏远了人民。我的意思是，这显然是民族主义情绪等的表现。但我认为结果让所有人都感到意外。七天后，叶利钦与乌克兰领导人和白俄罗斯领导人，在一个名叫别洛韦日的地方——戈尔巴乔夫背后的一个狩猎小屋里会面。
And they basically sign an agreement that they will, they're different republics, they will set up as independent states and they will be part of a commonwealth of independent states and they won't be part of the Soviet Union anymore. So you can sort of imagine this in a previous era, in a completely different political context. The reaction of the Kremlin would have been to just arrest them,
他们基本上签署了一项协议，即他们作为不同的共和国，将建立独立国家，他们将成为独联体（独立国家联合体）的一部分，不再是苏联的一部分。所以你可以想象在以前的时代，在完全不同的政治背景下，克里姆林宫的反应本应是直接逮捕他们，
put them in a gulag, send in the tanks, just crush it. But Gorbachev doesn't have that instinct. Whether the army would obey him anyway is very dubious. Power has left him. The old sort of structures have lost all credibility and self-belief. The old system collapsed before a new one had time to start working, apparently they said. That's what Gorby joff said
把他们送进古拉格，派遣坦克，彻底粉碎它。但戈尔巴乔夫没有这种本能。军队是否会服从他本身就很可疑。权力已经离他而去。旧的结构已经失去了所有的信誉和自信。“旧系统在新的开始工作之前就崩溃了，”他们显然是这么说的。戈尔巴乔夫就是这么说的，
isn't it in his christmas day speech so from that point from the 8th of december onwards the end of the serving union is absolutely inevitable i mean the republics are declaring then what happens is more and more republics don't want to be left behind so they start rush they rush to to declare their independence too and of course the reason for that is that the individual the sort of the old party barons in these places think, this is the way I will hold on to power because I will declare, you know, I will rush. Which is what Yeltsin had done.
不是吗，在他的圣诞节演讲中？所以从那一刻起，从12月8日开始，苏联的解体就绝对不可避免了。我的意思是共和国随后纷纷宣布独立。接下来发生的是越来越多不想落后的共和国也开始争先恐后地宣布独立。当然，原因在于，这些地方的旧党阀们认为，这是我保住权力的方式，因为我会宣布——我会赶快行动。也就是叶利钦做过的事。
Yeah, precisely. This is, I will reinvent myself as a nationalist. And this is the way I will, this is what the people do in Central Asia. This is what Putin does. So Gorbachev, suddenly he's there in the Kremlin, but basically he's leading a state that is crumbling around him that no longer exists and um I think on the 23rd of December he has a
是的，正是如此。这是——我会把自己重塑为一个民族主义者。这就是人们在中亚所做的事情，这也是普京所做的事情。所以戈尔巴乔夫，突然间他还在克里姆林宫里，但基本上他领导的是一个在他周围土崩瓦解、不再存在的国家。嗯，我认为在12月23日，他与叶利钦有了一次
meeting with Yeltsin um quite a tense a long meeting for hours where they agree that in two days time he will hand over the nuclear briefcase and he will basically give up power and this happens to be that day happens to be the 25th of December, which obviously for us is Christmas Day. Extraordinary kind of coincidence. So the stage is set then for this speech. Gorbachev is going to give this internationally televised speech, an absolute, an extraordinary moment in history that actually,
会面，这是一场相当紧张、持续数小时的漫长会面，他们同意在两天后他将移交核公文包，基本上交出权力，而那一天恰好是12月25日，对我们来说显然是圣诞节。一种非同寻常的巧合。因此，这场演讲的舞台已经搭好。戈尔巴乔夫将发表这场面向全球电视转播的演讲，这是历史上的一个绝对非同寻常的时刻，甚至直到现在，我认为西方人都没有完全理解，那个作为列宁、斯大林、勃列日涅夫和赫鲁晓夫的继承人将要辞职，并且国家将在电视直播中崩溃。现在他们想用摄像机——首先，俄罗斯电视台负责人对戈尔巴乔夫说：“如果你能在直播中签署辞职信，那将是极好的电视节目，你知道的，我们会把摄像机对准你。”戈尔巴乔夫说：“不，我不会那样做。等摄像机关掉后我再签。”然后是关于如何广播的问题。俄罗斯的——我的意思是，这是一个非同寻常的比喻。俄罗斯的摄像机——它们很大，很陈旧，基本上就像1950年代的摄像机之类的一样。
even now I think people in the West don't get their heads around enough, that the guy who was the successor to lenin and stalin and brezhnev and khrushchev is going to resign and and the state is going to collapse live on television um now they want to do it with the cameras uh first of all the head of russian tv says to gorbachev i want you to sign it'd be great television if you would sign the resignation live, like, you know, we'd have the cameras on you. And Gorbachev says, no, I won't do that. I'll sign it when the cameras aren't rolling. Then there's the question of how are they going to broadcast it? The Russian, I mean, this is an extraordinary metaphor. The Russian cameras are not, they're huge, they're antiquated, they're basically like cameras from the 1950s or something.
它们没有进行全球卫星广播的设施。所以CNN是莫斯科唯一拥有这些设施的人。所以是一个美国电视团队捕捉到了这些传遍世界的画面。这就像萨珊王朝皇帝把罗马皇帝当作上马石一样。汤姆，这甚至比那还要夸张，因为到了戈尔巴乔夫签署辞职信的时刻。办公室里——如果你看过总统发表演讲的录像的话——办公室里挤满了技术人员等等，其中大多数是美国人，而不是俄罗斯人，因为他们是为CNN工作的。戈尔巴乔夫去签署那张纸，结果笔坏了。俄罗斯的笔坏了。那是一支苏联笔。所以你知道他怎么做吗？他向一个人借了一笔钱——
And they don't have the facilities to do a kind of satellite broadcast around the world. So CNN are the only people in Moscow with the facilities to do it. So it's an American television crew that are going to capture these images that go around the world. It's like the Sasanian emperor using a Roman emperor as his mounting block. It's even more than that, Tom, because the moment comes for Gorbachev to sign the resignation. The office, if you've ever seen footage of presidents giving speeches, the office is out of shot.
CNN总裁汤姆·约翰逊（Tom Johnson），他递给他自己的万宝龙钢笔，一支不可能……资本主义的笔。终极资本主义钢笔。戈尔巴乔夫签了字，用那支资本主义钢笔签署了辞职信——终极资本主义钢笔。然后戈尔巴乔夫发表了这篇——大概20分钟还是30分钟的演讲，在演讲中他基本上表示，他为自己进行辩护，反对那种认为他无缘无故将国家陷入混乱的观点，因为他说我们必须改变，我们当时正在失败，你知道的，我知道事情并没有按预期发展，而且他非常……
It's packed with technicians and so on, most of whom are American, not Russian, because they're working for CNN. Gorbachev goes to sign the piece of paper, and the pen doesn't work. The Russian pen doesn't work. It's a Soviet pen. So do you know what he does? He borrows a pen from a man called Tom Johnson,
里面挤满了技术人员等，大多数是美国人，而不是俄罗斯人，因为他们是为CNN工作的。戈尔巴乔夫去签署那张纸，结果笔坏了。俄罗斯的笔坏了。那是一支苏联的笔。你知道他是怎么做的吗？他向一个叫汤姆·约翰逊的人借了一支笔，
the president of CNN, who hands him his Mont Blanc pen, a pen that could not be... A capitalist pen. The ultimate capitalist pen. And Gorbachev signs it, signs the resignation the ultimate capitalist pen uh and gorbachev and gorbachev signs it signs the resignation with the capitalist pen then he gives this um twin what is it 20 minute 30 minute speech where he basically says um he he he he defends himself against the idea that he has unnecessarily plunged the country into turmoil because he says we had to change we were failing you know i know it hasn't worked out and he's sort of this very
CNN的总裁，他递给他自己的万宝龙笔，一支不可能……资本主义的笔。终极的资本主义笔。戈尔巴乔夫签了字，用资本主义的笔签署了辞职信，终极的资本主义笔，然后戈尔巴乔夫进行了大约20到30分钟的双语演讲，他在演讲中基本上说……他为自己进行了辩护，反对那种认为他 unnecessarily 将国家陷入混乱的观点，因为他说我们必须改变，我们失败了，你知道的，我知道这并没有成功，他有点像这样一个非常……
sort of passionate defense of his of his own policies um and then but of course he's incredibly unpopular in russia to an extent that again i think people in the west don't really grasp we think of him as cuddly and liberal and we don't understand why but russians just look at him and they think this is the man who's destroyed our country and plunged us into an economic abyss so he's giving this sort of rather plaintive defense of his policies but it's actually too late uh then he finishes and then at 7 32 in this again fantastically symbolic moment the two workmen take down the red flag that flies over the Kremlin that has flown there since, effectively, kind of metaphorically, since the Russian Revolution, since the death of the Tsars and all that stuff.
对自己的政策进行了某种激昂的辩护，然后——但当然，他在俄罗斯极其不受欢迎，这种程度，我想西方人再次并没有真正理解。我们认为他可爱且开明，我们不明白为什么，但俄罗斯人看着他，认为这就是那个摧毁了我们的国家、把我们推入经济深渊的人。所以他发表了这种多少有点哀怨的辩护，但其实已经太晚了。然后他讲完，接着在7分32秒，在这个同样极具象征意义的时刻，两名工人在克里姆林宫上空降下了红旗。这面红旗自俄国革命以来、自沙皇陨落以及诸如此类的事情以来，实际上、可以说在某种程度上就一直在那里飘扬。
So down comes the red flag and up goes the white, blue and red tricolour of Russia rather than the Soviet Union. And then there are these two sort of rival drinking sessions. So Gorbachev goes into his office with a couple of his aides with a bottle of cognac and they, you know, they sort of reminisce about what went wrong and all this kind of thing. And meanwhile, Yeltsin. What's Yeltsin up to?
于是红旗落下，升起了代表俄罗斯而非苏联的白、蓝、红三色三色旗。然后是两场多少有点针锋相对的饮酒聚会。戈尔巴乔夫和他的几个助手带着一瓶干邑回到办公室，他们，你知道的，聚在一起回忆哪里出了问题诸如此类的事情。与此同时，叶利钦。叶利钦在干什么？
So Yeltsin also goes into an office with a bottle of cognac, but there are conflicting accounts. So some people say Yeltsin up to? So Yeltsin also goes into an office with a bottle of cognac. But there are conflicting accounts. Some people say Yeltsin and his mates got lashed, but others say Yeltsin was actually... Yeltsin was a much more anxious person than is often... In the West, he's often perceived as kind of jovial... Jovial drunk. Shambolic bear.
所以叶利钦也带着一瓶干邑进了一间办公室，但有相互矛盾的说法。所以有人说叶利钦在干什么？所以叶利钦也带着一瓶干邑进了一间办公室。但有相互矛盾的说法。有人说叶利钦和他的伙伴们喝得大醉，但也有人说叶利钦其实……叶利钦是一个比通常人们认为的要焦虑得多的人。在西方，他常常被看作是一个有些随和的人……随和的酒鬼。笨拙的巨熊。
Yeah, a bit of a kind of Boris Johnson, actually. You know, sort of a... A drunk Boris Johnson. Yeah, a drunk but slightly more of Boris Johnson, actually, you know, sort of a drunk Boris Johnson. Yeah, a drunk, but slightly more serious Boris Johnson. In fact, Yeltsin was much more kind of neurotic. And only a couple of years later, Yeltsin had basically had a nervous breakdown. And I think a lot of people say tried to kill himself. So Yeltsin is much more anxious. And some sources say Yeltsin didn't join in the drinking because he was so overawed by the responsibility that he knew was awaiting him.
对，有点像鲍里斯·约翰逊那种感觉。你知道的，有点像一个……喝醉了的鲍里斯·约翰逊。对，一个喝醉了但实际上更……更像鲍里斯·约翰逊的人，你知道的，有点像一个喝醉了的鲍里斯·约翰逊。对，一个喝醉了但稍微严肃一点的鲍里斯·约翰逊。事实上，叶利钦要神经质得多。仅仅几年后，叶利钦基本上就精神崩溃了。我想很多人说他曾试图自杀。所以叶利钦要焦虑得多。有些消息来源说叶利钦没有加入喝酒的行列，因为他对压在自己肩上、他深知在前方等待着他的责任感到过于敬畏。
So the Soviet Union comes to an end. George Bush interrupts his Christmas Day in America to give a speech to the American people saying, you know, the Soviet Union has ended over. We will work with Russia. We won, all that sort of stuff. USA, USA. Now, what you could say, Tom, is that this one reason
于是苏联走到了尽头。乔治·布什中断了他在美国的圣诞节假期，向美国人民发表讲话，说，你知道的，苏联已经结束了，结束了。我们将与俄罗斯合作。我们赢了，诸如此类的事情。美国，美国。现在，你可以说，汤姆，这是为什么
that this is such an important moment in our modern... Well, it's not just China. It's also because this is the point at which, in a way, you could argue, I mean, some people would say, Russia wasn't the West's to lose, but the West does lose Russia. Because what then happens to Russia... Yeah, all those kind of 20-year-old management consultants rushing, privatising everything.
这是我们现代生活中如此重要的一个时刻……好吧，不仅仅是中国的关系。这也是因为这是个转折点，在某种程度上，你可以说——有些人会说，俄罗斯本来就不是西方所能失去的，但西方确实失去了俄罗斯。因为接下来俄罗斯发生了什么……对，所有那些20多岁的管理咨询顾问蜂拥而至，把一切都私有化。
Yeah, everything goes horribly wrong for the russian people their their savings their pensions their living standards collapse the living standards of russian ordinary russians dip colossally in the next few years russia's so that's putin wars in china it matters massively for china because i think every chinese leader looks at the humiliations visited on gorbachev and thinks we're not going to allow that to happen. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. They definitely think that. So it's the making of Xi Jinping and of Putin.
是的，俄罗斯人民的一切都大错特错了。他们的积蓄、养老金、生活水平崩溃了。在接下来的几年里，普通俄罗斯人的生活水平急剧下降。所以俄罗斯的……这就是普京，对于中国来说，这极其重要，因为我认为每一位中国领导人看到降临在戈尔巴乔夫身上的羞辱，都会想：我们绝不允许这种事发生。是的，我觉得这完全正确。他们绝对是这么想的。所以这是塑造习近平和普京的关键。
Well, they think, they say this is what happens when you foolishly do political reform and economic reform at the same time. The political reform is you just throw away your power. You know, you need to do the economic reform. And the Chinese famously thought that Gorbachev was mad for doing these two things at once.
好吧，他们认为，他们说这就是当你愚蠢地同时进行政治改革和经济改革时会发生的事情。政治改革就是你直接放弃了权力。你知道，你需要进行经济改革。中国人历来认为戈尔巴乔夫同时做这两件事简直是疯了。
And of course, for Putin... Well, because the chairman had been, you know, in 89, summer of 89. Yeah. So they'd already decided on that policy. And never apologised for it. Now, for Putin, and so for people who are in our Rest Is History club,
当然，对于普京来说……好吧，因为主席曾在，你知道的，在89年，89年的夏天。对。所以他们已经决定了那个政策。而且从未为此道歉。现在，对于普京来说，以及对于我们“历史其余部分”俱乐部的人来说，
it's not too late to join up on Christmas Day, of course. It's still the Christmas present. It be Christmas without a hint of commercialism. For people in our Restless History Club who are on the Discord chat, they've been talking a lot about this in the last few weeks, about Gorbachev and Russia. And I think one of the key things when you're understanding Putin is for a lot of ordinary Russiansussians they say of course putin is better than the alternative because we tried the alternative in the 1990s and it was a complete
在圣诞节加入还为时不晚，当然。这依然是圣诞礼物。没有一丝商业气息的圣诞节算什么圣诞节呢。对于我们Discord聊天室里的“历史其余部分”俱乐部成员来说，他们在过去几周里一直在热烈讨论这个话题，关于戈尔巴乔夫和俄罗斯。我认为，当你试图理解普京时，最关键的一点在于，对许多普通俄罗斯人来说，他们会说，普京当然比替代方案要好，因为我们在20世纪90年代尝试过那个替代方案，结果完全
and utter disaster so this moment that we in the west think of as a moment of celebration and triumph the end of the ussr to you know more than 100 million people it's a moment of utter, as they see it, a moment of utter disaster and chaos and tragedy and so on. And arguably, I think the Coronation of Charlemagne obviously is, to me, the most famous Christmas Day event since the birth of Christ.
是一场彻头彻尾的灾难。所以，我们西方人认为是庆祝和胜利时刻的这一事件——苏联的解体——对于（你知道的）一亿多人的心目中，这是一场彻头彻尾的、如他们所见的一场彻底的灾难、混乱和悲剧的时刻。可以说是这样，我认为查理曼大帝的加冕礼显然对我来说是耶稣诞生以来最著名的圣诞节事件。
Was he born on Christmas Day? Well, that's the question, isn't it? But I think the end of the Soviet Union, we're still actually grappling to come to terms with it. Well, there's a wonderful symmetry there, isn't there? Because we've had the end of the Soviet Union, we're still actually sort of grappling to come to terms with it. Well, there's kind of wonderful symmetry there, isn't there? Because we've had the birth of an empire. And the death of an empire. And the death of an empire.
他是在圣诞节出生的吗？好吧，这正是问题所在，不是吗？但我认为苏联的解体，我们实际上仍在努力去接受它。好吧，这里有一种奇妙的对称性，不是吗？因为我们经历了苏联的解体，我们其实仍在某种程度上努力去接受它。好吧，这里有一种奇妙的对称性，不是吗？因为我们经历了一个帝国的诞生。以及一个帝国的消亡。以及一个帝国的消亡。
Tom, we couldn't have scripted it better. Yeah. And both very festive. Now, we should say that they will be the future editions of this podcast. Slightly less heavyweight. They will be less heavyweight. I look through my notes and I see the delights to come. I see the poetry
汤姆，我们简直写不出更好的剧本了。是的。而且都非常有节日气氛。现在，我们应该说，未来的这档播客节目将会推出。会稍微轻松一些。它们会不那么沉重。我翻看我的笔记，看到了即将来临的美妙内容。我看到了诗歌
of William McGonagall, the Battle of Wakefield, the Tay Bridge disaster, the birth of Queen Emma of Hawaii, the life of J.R.R. Tolkien, Albert Camus. We've got so many Christmassy
威廉·麦格纳戈尔的诗，韦克菲尔德战役，泰伊铁桥灾难，夏威夷埃玛王后的生平，J.R.R. 托尔金的生平，阿尔贝·加缪。我们有这么多的圣诞节
treats coming up. So one a day, one a day up to the 6th of January. So we'll have a podcast every day till then. And we look forward to talking to you for the next one, whether you like it or not. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
大餐即将上演。所以一天一个，一天一个一直到1月6日。所以在此之前我们每天都会有一期播客。无论你喜欢与否，我们都很期待在下一期节目中与你交流。再见。再见。
Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听独家放送、抢先体验、无广告节目并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。